hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to alone hi hello okay so as
soon as I load it in the game there was
a bit of backstory I'm here to help a
situation I can't breathe
and everything's gone to [ __ ] as is
evident by this guy over here hi how you
doing oh you don't look so good
do you need medical attention you look
like one of the people from soma that
the soma machine started to already take
over which is not good and also there's
a lot of weird sounds and also I thought
I heard something that was from SCP
containment breach but I don't know what
ARS is okay hi alright I'll get a move
on I'll skedaddle on out of here
and also there's radiation did I mention
that there's radiation and I'm an
engineer of some sort so I'm assuming
that my expertise is gonna get me out of
here or maybe I need to go through these
son of a [ __ ] doors Oh lovely oh this
doesn't look deadly at all oh I feel
very comfortable in these hallways
oh I'm sure my friends are gonna come
pouring out of the walls at any moment
okay so I'm assuming I need to use the
Geiger counter to try to know where they
are I don't know where I am cryo storage
mess hall infirmary bridge ah I don't
know where any of this is my arrow seems
to be pointing towards the BRIT no not
the bridge seems to be porting towards
quarters oh okay I need to go to the
quarters this way all crap hi is anybody
there
well I'm gonna go to the hall oh I've
never felt more comfortable being in the
hall what did I need to interact with
what the hell's in front of me
long interaction I don't know what that
meant what does that mean
where am I what am i doing oh geez
hello hello that's just a loop I'm gonna
be stuck forever down here hello I can't
go up this way
hello maybe I shouldn't have gone in the
goddamn vents
maybe I should have been a little what
is that interacting with okay already
then I'm out of here
doesn't see me to be anything in here
nothing on the Geiger counter so I'm
assuming I'm gonna be okay or generally
gonna be okay
I mean I'm gonna die that's evident at
least for now I'm gonna be kind of okay
hello hi hello anybody home
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay well yeah I'm starting to wish that
hadn't been brought on here why am I
always the engineer that gets brought on
to the death-defying alien infected
ships come on as a Clark said who I is
oh that one's already open why am I even
trying to bother who hi you feeling ill
are you missing some intestines ee my
objective marker is telling me somewhere
over here but I have no idea where that
was the loudest TV I've ever heard you
sack of [ __ ] what are you doing to me
doing a whole lot of nothing that's what
you're doing hello hi oh good oxygen
apparently I need that okay Boop
No alrighty oh jeez okay he's locked
myself in here why didn't they do that
when the aliens were coming around okay
I don't need to go to the mess hall I
need to go over here again the weird
sound effect that sounds like the whole
crumbling it around me don't know if I
like that oh well I I made it oh boy oh
boy oh boy
oh oh so I need to now seal the breach
because ah that is what that is it's the
Hulk rumbling and around us and probably
gonna kill all of us as soon as you let
her go down okay oh that's why I heard
it over here first oh I can see space oh
that's a bad thing okay don't worry guys
I got this engineering expert over here
went to many years
[Music]
okay I don't know if I want to do that
oh man oh space nice that's some quality
space there oh jeez that's not good oh
this is not good
hello hi okay alrighty then is anybody
home
[Music]
okay that's always nice to hear so the
infected kind of spread around
everywhere it does sound like a dead
space suit sorry it does sound like a
dead space situation going on here
there's some sort of infected and
they've got to fight him back at least
these guys seem to last a bit longer
than the issue Mora
so that's locked off but that's where I
need to go hey oh oh oh I should have
been looking at my Geiger counter hello
oh hello oh geez where is he
they didn't actually think there was
gonna be anything on this ship hello
okay I hear you
where is you okay alrighty then Oh son
of a [ __ ] don't do that do I need to
fix anything else god damn it okay
nothing in here trying to be thorough
about this and actually explore a bit
said I needed to go to the bridge but
it's kind of more over here well that
looks good oh it's just a it's all just
a big loop anyway so I can't go there is
that breathing why is it breathing on
the other side of the door oh hi oh good
oxygen tank speaking of breathing oh-oh
hi where are you oh thank good hi I want
to get good look at you oh hi
oh you're naked oh you're not as scary
now this is all sorts of bad this is
every sort of bad bridge briefing this
doesn't make any sense these things just
send me what is this
hi untextured console did I mention that
this game was a demo why do I gotta go
at the bloody van and I'm not English
bloody vent I'm talking about the vents
literally covered in blood all right
okay I'm going in the bloody vent then
no no then why did I come here there's
no point to any of this
what is that that doesn't help me
there's a bunch of nothing I didn't even
need to go in the vent
just could have gone around Oh what is
this I can't go here it's an invisible
wall over there oh jeez I don't know
[ __ ] shitty dicks a sheet it's high oh
he's still after me well I'm boned I'm
dying of radiation la da de da da da
okay oh he's still behind me okay I
think I lost him all right Scott damn
haven't I been here no there's a
different place yeah hi okay hi friend
welcome oh here let me through please
immediately now oh come on what am i
doing what am i doing what am i doing
how do I get through here the [ __ ] do I
do do I need like a keycard or something
I probably need a card or a key or a key
card type device or something of the
like
he's not nearby anymore this ain't good
this oh okay I thought he was there all
right so I gotta I gotta search this
place for something oh this is the
armory No
in tanks here torpedo Bay's lifepod why
can't I just get in these things what do
I need to stay why would they only send
one person doesn't make any goddamn
sense demonym just backtracking now nice
space
damn and I've managed to go all the way
back to the beginning which is not very
helpful at all but maybe there was
another way to go like over here yeah
maybe there we go okay so this is a new
section of the ship yeah it definitely
is
[ __ ] what kind of [ __ ] Welcome Party
is that just be happy that I'm here I'm
here to help
markiplier help will help me help Burton
but I'm still in trouble because I don't
have any protection from the monster
[Music]
Jesus where the hell is this I've never
been here what's that hello oh oh that's
so sad oh oh that story hi that's the
noise I heard for before that's from SCP
containment breach you can't fool me I
know all about that
I know hundred percent about that who's
there who is there I've got radiation on
the horizon and it's rising fast oh he's
getting close does he hear me
huh whoever it is it very unhappy hello
the scp-682 oh [ __ ] me
where is he you jeez you jeez which way
okay from down there do I need to go -
no I just came from cry of storage
didn't I say where I originally came
from either way I'm balling around he's
coming down oh I don't know where to go
hey buddy hey hey hey can you give me
directions around here I can't see a
goddamn thing this is a bad idea
hey hey friend hi are you you good oh
this this spells bad well that's more
than one that's more than one why did
that guy just stand there the [ __ ] hey
hey hey hey hey whoa hey oh okay you get
away from oh god where am i oh jeez oh
this is where I'm supposed to be
ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ] I've cornered man oh but
they didn't want to come near me the
[ __ ] is that for real
oh really so they don't come near me
hi buddy but they just stopped hey
what's wrong you shy oh come on it's me
come on take a picture with me it's okay
Wow son of a tits
well that sucked all right be right back
ah this would be helpful to me I did not
know about this this is um Han everybody
shut up shut up shut up for a goddamn
second okay Han alright so this is a map
who would have thunk tit it's a frickin
map so I'm in cryo storage so there's a
little icon of where I am there
legitimately were two entire halves of
the ship so I was very wrong in my
assumption I'd like complete I don't
know how I missed that there was a map
here but apparently I'm a freaking idiot
so I'll be right back because I am gonna
go explore in the back end of the ship
cuz there's got to be see ya how's
everything going over here huh
it's going good okay alright it's good
that's good friendly friendly place
friendly friendly place good oh hello
Oh more life pods hello yay it's really
fascinating because there's a lot of
story here I mean this is obviously just
a demo and the game is rough around the
edges but there does seem to be a really
interestingly crafted story here I want
to know more about it maybe do boo boo
boo boo boo boo let me off this [ __ ]
ship so these are the escape pods and it
seemed like either people used them
already or they're out of operation I
don't know which is which but I'm gonna
still try to find the way out of here
and apparently I'm headed to the engine
room I don't know why I need to go there
not like I'm gonna be able to fire up
the engines oh [ __ ] is he in there
why is it so dark why is it dark why is
it so dark in there
I can't go in there okay that's why it's
so dark it won't let me in there so I'm
assuming with the demo there's just
areas of this game that it's not gonna
let me in shut the [ __ ] up I'm talking
here yeah so it's just it's not let me
in there all right that's stupid
alrighty then well here's a radiation
room can I go into the radiation oh hi
what are you are you just for convenient
radiation Bala's well this this isn't
even on the map here well this is
unmarked territory why is this here are
all the vents not on the map might be
true apparently there's the armory just
around the corner here armory
wait yeah this is it's not it
this is not it armory armory oh Jesus I
can't go in here either
when I just keep the door closed then
don't give me false hope Oh
oh this is um dense that doesn't sound
good wherever I am it ain't good
also being around these corpses have
infected people is that gonna so I'm
gonna in fact me oh what's under the
drape I don't want to know some kind of
statue okay what the [ __ ] was that
why did everything go quiet there I
gotta admit that was like the creepiest
thing that's happened thus far I mean
everything else has been random haunted
house noises but then I thought that was
the thing I thought I was gonna die hey
all right can I get in the infirmary is
that a thing that I can get into
probably not considering everything else
seems to be closed off hello oh I can oh
geez oh well I already heard this story
about the nurse who was in here or the
doctor or whatever ah
what the [ __ ] is that you keep doing
random [ __ ] things to me goddamn is
scarier than anything else in this
goddamn game alright okay carrying on
can't go the engine-room
can't go anywhere [ __ ] where more
story
ah I have no idea what to say to that
because Wow all right then um yeah
that's not good but I'm assuming that
these aren't entities from the darkness
demons spawn come to claim you it's
gotta be bile whoa there's got to be
some sort of biology to him right can't
just be all chaos and her [ __ ] Allah
sness so I think I've been just about
everywhere Hey hi friend how you doing
now goes a long way around don't you
mind me don't you mind me one bit geez
another one Aqil knuckle
well [ __ ] okay I'll go the long way
around don't you mind me I'll be fine
all right you have a good one [ __ ] off
ah that's not good oh where am I now Oh
which way do I go
there's miracle okay gonna go this way
I'll circle back to the briefing room oh
yes god damn it that guy is persistent
that guy is way more persistent than he
was before so I can't go through there I
definitely can't cannot so if I go down
here I should be able to get somewhere
where I can get to one of these other
rooms yeah this is whoa hey hello there
yep sooner or later that's probably what
they count on okay ah Thank You oxygen I
need that even though I'm about to die
and I don't think I'm gonna be able to
progress much more because getting to
the bridge I don't think it's an option
just because if I can't go through there
I think that's just part of the demo
that's not available yet so I'm pretty
sure yeah I'm pretty sure there's just
nothing left to do on this one as far as
I know because there's just oh hi hello
hi Jesus yeah because if you go here and
there's nothing that you can do because
that won't open and you're just stuck
here and I've been everywhere so it's
not like there's you know not like
there's an endless list of things that
you could do yeah because this one's
close too so I don't know how to get to
the bridge and it says search for an
officer on the bridge so I don't think I
can get in there the objective marker is
there so I'm assuming this is just
undone but this is good framework here
there's good story here and this good
like there's a good world to open up a
whole lot of things and I'm getting
radiation poisoning right out it don't
feel too good could you stop that thank
you
that's all of this game for now if you
find more stuff to do let me know down
in the comments below provide a link for
this game down the description below so
thanks again and as always I will see
[Music]